light attacks will prevent the enemy's
posture from restoring fully but you'll
need to employ jumping attacks charged
R2 attacks or strong charged spells if
you want to consistently break the
posture of your enemies of course there
are other ways to break their Potter as
well such as the new countering system
with shields and also the parrying
system here's the thing a lot of this is
even possible on bosses and yes all the
bosses have this hidden posture bar as
well alright so in the clip here you can
see me staggering the Glenstone Dragon
using the rock sling spell which is made
more powerful by the meteorite staff I'm
using it took three of these spells in
roughly a 15 to 20 second window or so
to consistently break his posture now
because this posture bar is hidden to
the player the only way you'll know how
much damage you need is by experimenting
with different attacks on various
enemies here against Bulls the carrion
Knight after fighting him a few times I
realized that one charged R2 attack and
two are two jumping attacks were enough
to stagger him you can keep the enemy's
posture bar from fully recovering by
hitting them with light attacks